[Music]
on this Friday night gazin hospitals
Under
Siege the latest bombings to hit the
strip's largest medical facility if
there is a hell on Earth today its name
is Northern Gaza what both sides are
saying about the strike as thousands of
people try to find a safe place to hide
honoring service and sacrifice long
ignored a lot of people don't know and
understand what they have done a Dutch
couple goal to celebrate Canada's
indigenous
soldiers and vision of optimism the
veteran who received the world's first
eye
transplant global national with baren
Asser good evening to you thanks for
joining us tonight there are reports of
explosions and shelling on or near
multiple Gaza hospitals this evening
including the AL rentis Children's
Hospital some hospitals are now fully
out of power and conducting surgery by
flashlight while the Israeli military
continues to close
in this is Gaza City's largest hospital
alifa it has begun the daunting task of
evacuating thousands of people
Sheltering there and the near impossible
task of keeping its sickest patients
safe while doing so the head of the who
told the United Nations security Council
this afternoon on average a child is
being killed every 10 minutes in
Gaza we have very serious concerns that
these amount to disproportionate attacks
in preach of international humanitarian
law according to the IDF more than
100,000 residents have fled south over
the last two days Israel says it
captured key Hamas outposts in Gaza City
today killing some 150 of what it calls
Terror operatives in the process it also
claims that this video shows a Hamas
military operation that's being run next
to what it says is a school near gaza's
alifa
Hospital also today a harder push from
Western leaders for an ease in the
fighting French president Emanuel mcon
urged Israel to stop the bombing in an
exclusive interview with the BBC today
saying they must stop killing babies and
women in Gaza and the US Secretary of
State says more needs to be done to
prevent Ian deaths far too many
Palestinians have been killed far too
many have suffered uh these past weeks
and we want to do everything possible to
prevent harm to
them this deadly conflict is brutal and
horrific so we want to warn you that the
details and images in this story are
disturbing Danielle hamam Jin begins our
coverage
tonight listen
carefully that's the sound of a shell
hitting the courtyard of alifa Hospital
in Northern Gaza the video was filmed by
Ahmed hijazi who's been documenting
events here every day listen now to the
screaming this boy's leg had to be
amputated in the same hospital where he
was seeking
shelter
oh God why she screams the local
Authority run by Hamas says the hospital
complex was hit up to five times on
Friday the Israeli military claims an
errant missile launched by a Palestinian
terror group hit the hospital it's also
repeatedly accused Hamas of operating
its main command center underneath the
hospital if there is a hell on Earth
today its name is Northern Gaza and what
what do you
tell your children in such a situation
it's almost
unimaginable that the fireworks that
they see in the sky is out to kill
them cuz that's what it looks like and
this is what no anesthesia on a child
sounds
like the pain is excruciating as it is
for her father who can do nothing but
watch it makes my heart suffer he says
as Israeli tanks roll deeper into The
Enclave thousands of gazin keep moving
south for hours they walk not
necessarily to safety but to where it's
less dangerous or so they're
told some left Al shifa Hospital fearing
another attack on the
building there's nothing left to say no
words we saw death with our own eyes she
says this man can't find his mother or
his sister well I'm I I'm
find a solution he says this is not a
life Israel has agreed to hold its fire
for four to 6 hours a day along two
humanitarian corridors to allow
civilians to flee with a promise they
can
return but generations of Palestinians
have had to abandon their homes before
never able to go back
it's why so many waited this long to
leave the displacement that's happened
to the Palestinian people it's been in
our memories for a long time he says and
today the displacement that's taking
place it's bigger than
1948 to so many this is history
repeating itself 1948 is of course
referred to as the nakba the catastrophe
when more than 700,000 Palestinians fled
or were expelled from what is now Israel
the UN says so far about 1.5 million
people in Gaza have been displaced
far Danielle hjan in Jerusalem thank you
for your coverage
[Applause]
Danielle there were more protests in the
West Bank today with Palestinians
rallying in solidarity with the people
of Gaza a number of them showing signs
of support for Hamas there was also more
fighting with Israeli forces who have
ramped up operations in the West Bank
since the October 7th
attack but even before Hamas attacked
Israel 2023 was already the deadliest
year on record for Palestinians living
in the Israeli controlled West Bank
according to the United Nations today
the un's High Commissioner for human
rights called on Israel to protect them
but Rising tensions in the weeks since
have only made the situation worse Mike
Armstrong
reports
this is a place not unaccustomed to
clashes with soldiers leading to Deaths
but on this day the West Bank City of
Janine buried
[Applause]
11 Israeli Defense Forces rolled in
early Thursday morning as part of what
the IDF calls a counterterrorism
operation it was special forces at first
then it called in
reinforcements the IDF says it was
targeting Islamic Jihad facilities it
says it seized explosives weapons and
ammunition arrested 20 people and killed
12 those are numbers that can't be
confirmed but it's clear civilians got
caught up in what
happened they say they're targeting
terrorists this woman says but we were
just two women and three
children now between clashes with the
Israeli military and faceoffs with
settlers in the first 9 months of this
year according to the UN about 200
Palestinians were killed well things
have gotten
worse in just the last month and a half
176 West Bank Palestinians have been
killed including 43
children continued widespread impunity
for the un's commissioner for human
rights said Friday Israel as the
occupying force in the West Bank has to
do more to protect Palestinians from
violence
there's also been a sharp increase he
says in Settlers taking over land in the
West
Bank since 7 October nearly 1,000
Palestinians from at least 15 hering
communities have been forced from their
hes the alaro refugee camp had its own
violence this week two young men were
killed according to a local politici
shot by IDF soldiers during a March in
solidarity with Gaza oh
the Camp's mayor says the men posed no
threat to the soldiers but that that
didn't matter he says this is the most
dangerous time he remembers it is also
the most painful the majority in this
region has family in Gaza some we met
told us they've lost dozens of family
members in Israel's Invasion they've
been watching the images on television
and getting messages from loved ones in
the middle of it
the mayor says it seems indiscriminate
and that the International Community
doesn't care the fear now is that it
also feels as though things will
continue to get worse before they get
better Mike Armstrong global news Al
arub refugee camp the West
Bank the tension in the Middle East is
also igniting anger in Canada an indigo
store in downtown Toronto was vandalized
with red paint this morning posters of
its Jewish CEO and founder Heather
Risman were also plastered on its
Windows accusing her of funding genocide
Toronto police say there's been a spike
in reports of hate crimes since Hamas
attacked Israel on October 7th its hate
crime unit is
investigating we have alarming New
Revelations tonight about a growing
danger to Canada's security Massie Alina
Jad has been an outspoken critic of the
Islamic Republic of Iran's human rights
record for years now in an excl
exclusive interview with global news she
reveals details about the threat of the
Iranian regime on Canadian soil Nar
mosah
reports watching videos of Iranian
government forces attacking protesters
during last year's woman life Freedom
Movement prominent Iranian American
activist Massi aliad wants us to know
the threat of the Iranian regime is
right here in Canada FBI told me that as
far as you are in America we will
protect you but we suggest you not to go
to Canada it won't be safe for you
that's heartbreaking Canada should be
safe Ali NAD says the FBI told her if
she absolutely insists on visiting
Canada they need at least 3 months to
ensure her security what I constantly
hear from Iranian Americans they say the
problem in Canada is far far worse than
you could imagine this former special
adviser on at the US state department
says such extreme security precautions
for a trip to Canada are not normal that
sounds like if she were going to Turkey
or or Iraq it shouldn't be the case um
that when you're going to Canada um that
you have to spend months in advance
making sure that you're going to be
safe exiled in 2009 Ali NAD has long
been a thorn in the Iranian regime's
side and her criticism has put her in
extreme Danger in 2021 the FBI thwarted
an alleged kidnapping plot against aliad
the following year an alleged
assassination attempt they say both were
connected to the Islamic Republic the
regime has conducted over 360 Terror uh
assassinations in its 44-year history
the question is are authorities taking
that problem seriously in Canada
unfortunately the answer appears to be
no so you see Killing taking hostage
murdering executing is in the DNA of the
Islamic Republic so maybe you think that
this is some problem with Iranians let
them deal with it it's not Islamic
Republic is a threat to Canadians narah
Global
News and you can catch the new realities
full investigation tomorrow at 7 on
global our redacted transcript has now
been released of testimony involving a
former high-ranking RCMP intelligence
official
Cameron ordis is accused of leaking
classified information to targets of
criminal investigations he took the
stand earlier this month saying he was
protecting Canada when he shared Secrets
David Akin's been pouring over the
documents Cameron Oris was arrested in
2019 has pleaded not guilty and the
first thing he told the court when he
took the stand last Thursday November
2nd was that he's lost his pension his
professional standing and that he spent
three years in jail waiting for this
trial family stood by me he told the
court friends did not in some sense I
regret everything that's happened over
the last four years to everyone but what
I did was not
wrong that information was in 75 pages
of transcripts just released late
Thursday by federal prosecutors that
transcript describes how ordis began an
investigation in 2011 that was given the
code name
Skyfall Skyfall Oris told the court was
all about quote money laundering that
was threatening the integrity and the
fabric of the Canadian Financial system
he went on to say quote an an
extraordinary amount of money was being
laundered through Canada and its closest
partners and compromises financial
institutions in three of the five eyes
countries the big piece of that threat
as I read it was here in Canada ortis
testified that hostile State actors were
thought to be behind the money
laundering including Iran seeking to get
around International sanctions by
laundering money in Canada and funneling
it to terrorist groups like Hamas and
Hezbollah eventually the federal cabet
of the day it was the Harper government
in charge of the time was briefed on
Skyfall and cabinet decided to make the
Skyfall project one of the operational
priorities for the entire Canadian
intelligence Community late Friday
prosecutors released hundreds more pages
of transcripts of oris's subsequent
testimony in that closed courtroom
Global News is now reviewing those
transcripts ortis returns to the stand
Tuesday David Aken Global News Ottawa a
murderous plot that Edmonton Police call
Sick and Twisted coming up why
investigators believe someone wanted a
child
dead in Edmonton police are
investigating a Brazen daylight shooting
at a busy shopping plaza that left a
father and his young son dead
investigators say the father was the
Target but they believe the 11-year-old
boy was also intentionally
shot this lying in the sand with with
organized crime it's just changed like
that
is sick and twisted
and I think most gang members would
agree investigators did not name the boy
but identify the father as 41-year-old
harprit upal police say he is a
highlevel gang member in involved in the
drug trade another child a friend of the
son was in the vehicle at the time of
the shooting he was able to escape
unharmed so far no arrests have been
made in Winnipeg a former coach for
hockey Manitoba is charged with more
than a dozen criminal offenses including
sexual assault sexual exploitation
luring and possessing child pornography
police alleged that 28-year-old Madison
beuck allegedly groomed and gained the
trust of a Teenage player under her
supervision police say they were first
tipped off by a third party before the
Survivor came forward with details
leading to beux
arrest ahead a world first and major
step forward in restoring
[Music]
sight
Me singer songwriter siza solidified
herself as the lead Contender for the
66th Grammy Awards with a total of nine
nominations today's nominations added to
her tally over the years and made Taylor
Swift the first artist to score seven
nominations in the song of the year
category if there is an overall trend in
the 2024 nominations it's that the
majority of the leading nominees are
women surgeons in New York have
performed the world's first whole eye
transplant in a living person the
21-hour surg included the left eye and
parts of the face all from a single
donor doctors say the eye now has
well-functioning blood vessels and a
retina that looks promising Aaron James
a military veteran survived a high
voltage electrical accident that
destroyed the left side of his face he
still can't see out of the eye but the
surgery is considered a
breakthrough even if I can't see which I
didn't have an either to begin with you
know after the
accident you know maybe at least you
know y'all can learn something to help
the next
person doctors say there's still a
chance he could regain sight in the
transplanted eye James says the surgery
was life-changing and that he's grateful
beyond
words the ultimate sacrifice next how a
Dutch couple is honoring Canada's
indigenous
soldiers
near the end of the second world war
Canadian soldiers helped Liberate the
people of the Netherlands from Nazi
occupation more than 7,000 of them lost
their lives in the 8-month campaign and
are now resting in military cemeteries
across the country indigenous soldiers
played an important role in The
Liberation and a Dutch couple is making
a special effort to ensure they receive
the tribute they deserve Heather YX West
explains Stanford solace a member of the
Willis tuway first nation was 22 years
old when he enlisted in the Canadian
Armed Forces and 28 when he died no
Uncle Sanford did not come home sadly he
had sustained a according to what the
military uh record say a brain
hemorrhage from a fall he had
experienced buried among hundreds of
other soldiers at the Holton War
Cemetery in the Netherlands Solace has
long been recognized for his service as
a Canadian service member but not as an
indigenous Soldier until now it's
important to be able to recognize the
indigenous contribution because a lot of
people don't know and understand what
they have done throughout our Canadian
history a history where generations of
indigenous people have been mistreated
and oppressed after learning about the
horrors of residential schools a Dutch
couple felt compelled to help we thought
well we we give them more attention here
and how can we do that uh we do that
through uh the soldiers Ivonne and Barry
swof operate the only Canadian Legion
Branch in the Netherlands working with
Veterans Affairs Canada they created the
indigenous Legacy project earlier this
year you can imagine hon has
1394 Graves and then you have to search
finally we found 17 of them but maybe
there are more but 17 at the moment who
were First Nations in September 13 of
those soldiers were honored when a
delegation of family and community
members traveled to the grave sites this
was was really a First Nation ceremony
and we get goosebumps yeah yeah yeah
Ottawa has committed to more trips as
the project expands to identify
indigenous graves in military cemeteries
across Europe I took a braid of sweet
grass from my home and I left it there
at the foot of his headstone a special
opportunity to honor indigenous veterans
while connecting them back to their
culture and their home Heather urick
West Global
News and tomorrow Global News will have
special coverage including a
presentation of Remembrance Day the
service that's happening in Ottawa our
coverage begins at 10:30 a.m. eastern
730 Pacific on global and on all our
streaming
platforms and that's global national for
this Friday night I'm far anaser ahe of
Remembrance Day your Canada is a special
tribute on the shores of mlet Nova
Scotia this large sand drawing in the
shape of a poppy apply titled remember
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good
[Music]
night